we have this from Newsweek white
supremacist march on DC Sparks
conspiracy theory FBI was involved so
the group is called Patriot front and
I've seen a bunch of people on the right
say that journalists as well as
personalities that I think Elijah
Shaffer was saying that he's really well
connected on the right he knows a lot of
people from various different groups
he's talked to them he's interviewed
them and he knows no one associated with
Patriot front I thought that was very
interesting because you know I've been
to a lot of these events I used to go on
the ground and do a lot of reporting
I've interviewed a lot of people and
I've never met a single person who was
associated with whatever this group is
not that I'm on the ground in the past
few years anyway so maybe it's an it's
it's a new I guess in the past five
years or so but the funniest thing about
it is we have this uh clip from Joe
wrote The Joe Rogan Experience of uh the
Patriot front March I want to show you
an image of these individuals you can
see they all have these hats they have
these masks they all wear masks they
have shields they all wear the same
things like somebody ordered the same
blue jacket like 300 of them they all
wore the same thing they ordered the
same White net Gators the same khakis
the same boots so really well organized
I suppose and then I want to show you
what Joe Rogan had to say in response to
seeing this video I think he was on on a
show with Matt taibi good these guys
where's the fat people
[Laughter]
in the same clothes do that again what
the is this is that have you ever
seen anything that looks more where's
the fat people tell me that doesn't look
like feds
right it's like the 101st Airborne
Runners these guys look at they just got
out of buds I mean what the out of
here
the so uh so I saw someone
comment you know it's not real because
whenever you see an actual right-wing
militia group they're all morbidly obese
or at least a handful of them are not
all of them and it's like that that's
actually fairly interesting now I have
seen people push back and say don't
underestimate them they like that
they're being called feds the action the
reality is someone posted an image from
an internal FBI report where the FBI
actually warns that among the FBI half
of the agents are morbidly obese so this
act so it's actually the other way
around and the argument is the actual
white nationalists do fight and train
and and so it may be it may be real I
don't know I honestly I don't know what
to think all I know is it's weird this
group has has police protection they
were they were a lot they did this March
where they then were given an escort to
to the subway where no cleared for them
right it was cleared for them and no one
was allowed to go in after them they've
loaded into trucks under police watch
and guard and then left so Joe Rogan may
be right about this yeah we're the fat
people funny story I was actually
walking through DC and I stumbled upon
them while they were doing this so I was
speaking unintentional journalist yeah I
was doing my journalistic duties and I
had thought they were Patriot front
because I've obviously been to a lot of
trump rallies and you know been been
around and I know this isn't necessarily
evidence or fact based but you can get a
vibe from people who are there to
protest for the right reasons you know
there's just sort of a vibe to the Trump
crowd or people who are there whatever
the issue is because you can tell that
they really want to be there and they're
talking to other people who aren't
necessarily there to attend the rally
but they're trying to sort of
proselytize and like spread the cause
and spread the word and it was such an
odd Vibe and I know that's not again
doesn't mean much but I had just never
seen a group of people protesting who
were allegedly so patriotic acting the
way that they were just walking it was
so where's antifa it was bizarre
hogamatifah's not protesting any of
these guys no serious question yeah
where are they at well and why do they
have a police escort right like so when
I first saw a picture that someone was
like oh it's like Charlottesville and
like the unite the right walk and I was
like this looks way more organized than
that did uh Zeke Arkham on Twitter had
this his thing and I guess he's in law
enforcement he was saying like there's
photos of them being arrested
theoretically except they all still have
their masks on and they're kneeling and
he's basically going through being like
you wouldn't let them continue to wear
their masks because you have to make
sure they're breathing when they're in
police custody like you wouldn't have
them kneeling in this position like none
of this makes sense it's almost like
you're waiting to hear like oh actually
the whole thing was staged for a movie
and they're filming it and this is what
they think this is like it it seems so
strange especially since there are
police involved like this is not
normally how police respond to any kind
of right group extremists or not uh
demonstrating publicly they usually have
very little police police support that
was funny when Joe's like where are the
fat people at that's it's it's real
though that's very real
yeah I don't know what do you guys think
friends look I mean
I have no idea but it's not something
that would be shocking if it came out
right like my instinct is just to assume
that something's up at this point I I
mean there are it's almost foolish to
not actively distrust them right
so I don't know are there there's
obviously there's not feds but there's
stories about this these antifa guys
getting picked up driven around the
block and then let go that's what they
do with informants I wouldn't be
surprised I mean there were Federal FBI
informants on the ground on January 6
which apparently was also planned so
therefore the FBI knew about it question
mark like none of it makes sense the
thing about this is like it's just so
uniform they all are like in the
sunglasses and the hat and the exact
same jacket like I just really don't
think there's it's too precise for it to
seem like inorganic movement it just
immediately hits like the left-wing
social media machine the you know blue
check mark the angry blue check marks on
Twitter and the mainstream media it just
I I don't know I feel like it's not even
it wasn't even about the March itself
it's how it gets rolled out and then
it's used as a pretext to start a
broader narrative about how white
supremacy and nationalism and xenophobia
are on the rise and so we you know and
then but then they made the jump we need
to crack down on you know random Twitter
user one two three right were they were
there any chance like was there any
chanting was there any demands what was
the message like I don't understand
other than the fact that his paper front
like what is the theoretical racial
messaging behind this this activity
there's almost no media about it they
don't have any media presence I don't
see anything about them about Patriot
rather than stuff that's very nicely and
this specific demonstration like I don't
where is the chanting like we got some
great sound bites from previous events
really fishy right yeah but the media
has declared that it's a white
supremacist event um
Russia hoax right that's what that's
what I think yeah I feel like the FBI is
gonna be like it was actually just a
drill we were just practicing to see
what would happen this was literally
just I mean a block away from where they
were marching so no hold on I'm not I'm
not some kind of conspiracy theorist
lunatic who is going to say that these
guys they're protesting on Thursday
after they March this last week I am not
some conspiracy theory lunatic who is
going to say this is feds the obvious
explanation is these are Russian Agents
from the Kremlin
because Putin wants to reform the USSR
yes no they they they're Soviet and they
were they were sleepers and when the
Soviet Union collapsed they didn't know
because they were brainwashed and then
because Putin wants to bring the Soviet
Union back he activated the radio signal
which oh my God he triggered all of them
into acting for uh the Soviet Union just
like as a journalist that person could
never say that the United States
government did anything wrong because
being a journalists offending the United
States government yeah my anonymous
source told me that think about that so
I you think about how insane that story
is about Trump in the elevator where it
said somewhere something Trump did
something like that yes that starts with
like some rumor and then a bunch of
journalists who are psychopaths chase
after this insane rumor imagine what's
going to happen when someone gets an AI
generated image on their phone and they
go to a journalist and intelligence
agencies will do this and they'll be
like journalist I can't give you the
photo because I'll get arrested because
it's classified but take a look at this
and they'll show a low-res AI I
generated image of Donald Trump you know
juggling bowling pins or something and
then they'll be like it's real and then
they'll be like but I can't give it to
you but you know keep it on the DL that
journalist then goes and tells their
boss I saw the picture it was Donald
Trump juggling bowling pins I swear you
know this is this is a source is good
I've checked his credentials they're
gonna go wow maybe we should run it and
then just like BuzzFeed news released
the steel dossier they will report
source that FBI confirms Donald Trump
juggles bowling pins and they'll just
walk right into fake news
that's where we're going I think that we
should start doing this on purpose
though like you should write down piece
of paper hold up to video camera with
today's date The Story You're gonna tell
every left-wing journalist that you know
and then wait until it becomes
mainstream news and then be like by the
way that was false like I know that
sounds like spreading just information
but you should just point out that there
are leaks that that there are people who
take this information and intentionally
try to paint everyone you know in a bad
light I think it's only a matter of time
before those Tucker Carlson leaked
videos
get revealed to be deep fix or at least
one of them because I think about this
Media Matters will publish anything
and so what someone could theoretically
do is take 10 real videos make one deep
fake video Give Them All to a leftist
organization who will publish them all
then definitively prove the Deep fake
one by showing a video of them making it
and say your fake news and you make up
stories then what happens the subject of
those deep fakes can file a massive
defamation lawsuit for the publication
of a deep fake with with proof and then
what's going to happen is they're going
to say we didn't know it was a deep fake
and I have to argue to the court they
thought it was real because of a source
giving it to them and then the argument
can be made no they're lying we want
Discovery we think they made it
themselves and then the question is
where did they get it they're gonna have
to reveal a bunch of information and
it's going to destroy whatever smidgen
of credibility they may have had with
anybody someone tweeted at me I can't
watch right now since Ryanair but they
tweeted something to me that has 55 000
likes it was posted yesterday and it's a
Fed gets recognized and called out at
their staged Patriot front March who's
who tweeted it um this is from
um
did you retweet it no no I have not
retweeted it I can send it to you
um just retweet it it looks like like a
mega account I have no idea if it's if
it's uh legitimate or not but someone
just told me in this so it could be fun
to watch
I just don't understand like what this
protest is like I'm sorry they just
walked through DC and they didn't say
anything and then they got on the subway
banner and it said something to the
effect of I think like reclaim or
rebuild the family
so they're Pro Derek talking extreme
that's true hold on hold on I like this
it's not a white Ceramics group it's
just a real family name families or
something what does that mean like
they're just a pro family group this is
a pro family extremist group so they're
getting it wrong must have reclaimed oh
Sheamus uh Sheamus just retweeted it
yeah pull it up let's play it
you're video saving us that's not
acceptable this is a public place your
video you're trying to get us in trouble
sir you go find one I'm deleting the
video no you're not gonna touch my phone
you're not taking a video of us
when I look at my master I recognize you
yeah I know you do
so give me my phone I'm deleting the
video
this guy literally walked up to him and
said in the most license in registration
tone I've
camera you cannot film that video going
to delete this video no you're not going
to touch my phone you're not taking a
video of us I mean a lot of cops would
do that I reckon I understand this yeah
taking two parties one tyranny recording
where is so this is from yesterday where
where uh James O'Keefe's trying to get a
whistleblower where where's antifa man
antifa the one time we actually need
your help to go out and film these guys
and figure out who they are y'all know
where to be found maybe that's the
limits test antifa is not there and
therefore this is not real like fat on
it's like yeah exactly the feds aren't
going to go film themselves why would
and typical film Patriot front dude fat
on fed crime makes me so sad I wish they
got along better you ever see hear those
stories about like the FBI and the DEA
stinging each other yes like the DEA is
trying to sell drugs to the FBI and
they're like freeze federal law
enforcement wait so are we wait what's
going on when I was a kid there was
three million dollars when I was a kid
there was like a car at the end of our
block being super sketchy uh and so my
mom called the police she's like look
there's something really weird going on
I don't know what what it is and then
the police came and it turned out that
they were undercover cops like
pretending to commit a crime to like try
to entrap somebody or catch them or
something so we turned uh we we turned
the feds against each other
my mom called the police on the police
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time